When you are working in Chimera, you will usually
be visualizing protein structures. However, it is
also possible to visualize structures containing
both protein and nucleic acid components.
For example, here we have the PDB entry 1hys,
a reverse transcriptase enzyme from HIV.
To change the depiction of the
nucleotides that the enzyme is holding,
we can go to Actions, Atoms and Bonds, and
Nucleotide Objects. Under Settings we see a
panel containing the various depiction options.
For example, under the side chain section,
we can change the Fill/Slab to Ladder. Now the
slabs are replaced with rods as shown on screen.
Chimera contains many other useful depiction
options under the Tools menu. For example,
under Depiction, we can color the structure
according to a rainbow color scheme. I'm using
the default color range as shown here, but you
can customize your own colors in the color editor.
When we hit Apply, the structure is colored
according to the range set above, starting with
blue at each N-terminus and ending with red at
each C-terminus. Because this protein contains two
chains, there are a total of four termini in the
structure, two of which are highlighted on screen.
Under Tools and Depiction, we can also color
by secondary structure. If we apply the default
settings, alpha helices are colored red, beta
sheets purple, and coils gray. Notice that
this coloration only applies to the protein
part of the structure, not the nucleic acids.
Here I have recolored the structure to a more
uniform color scheme to demonstrate some of the
advanced effects that Chimera has to offer. Under
Actions and Ribbon, we can activate Ribbon Edging.
This gives the ribbons thicker and more clearly
defined edges. For more effect options, we can
go to Tools, Viewing Controls, and open up the
Effects panel. Among the variety of effects shown
here is Depth Cueing. If we turn off Depth Cueing,
the structure takes on a much flatter appearance.
You can also activate Silhouettes, which
give the structure a darker outline.
You can adjust parameters such as width and
color. For the most clearly defined outlines,
set the transparency under A all the way
up to 1 and change the color to black.
Finally, you can turn on Shadows for
a more three-dimensional appearance.
Another interesting feature to explore
is the Side View. Using this feature,
you can slice through the structure to
determine how much of it you will see.
You can also use Chimera to emulate the
distinctive art style that David Goodsell
uses in his "Molecule of the Month" column
on PDB101. In the examples shown on screen,
we can see that this style is characterized by
flat lighting and the use of individual atoms
as opposed to ribbons. To achieve this
style, the first step is to go to Tools,
Viewing Controls, and Lighting. Here, we can
change the lighting from its default setting
to Ambient. This creates the distinctive
flat look. With the lighting configured,
we can now go to Actions and show the
atoms and bonds. Then we must hide the
protein ribbons by setting the selection
mode to Append, selecting chains A and B,
and under Actions, choosing Ribbon Hide. With the
selection cleared, we can change the atoms and
bonds depiction to Sphere. The result bears some
resemblance to the art style of David Goodsell.
You can take this one step further by going
to Actions, Color, and choosing By Element.
Now each atom in the protein is colored according
to the standard elemental coloration scheme.